foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
the elephant
in the room
or the mayor
or your local councilman
maybe your local state representative or
governor in the room with you and your
doctor as you make your medical
decisions I mean that's what Dr Maman Oz
says that obviously obviously when
people are making medical decisions
about medical procedures that they're
going to have you want to have you your
doctor and your local politicians making
those decisions it's super important
it's super important
that you discuss your health issues with
the mayor of the city that you live in
and the City Council in which you live
in
before you were to have medical
treatment it's very important this is
super super uh important policy that uh
Dr Oz has put forward as a Senate
candidate
in Pennsylvania by way of New Jersey
you know what I'm talking about this is
absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous look Dr Oz
stepped in it and here is why because he
wants to have it both ways he wants to
say oh no oh the the the decision
between a woman for abortion between a
woman and her doctor I believe in that
but I also want local politicians to
tell a woman exactly what to do and what
a doctor can and cannot do
he wants to have it both ways he tried
to phrase it he didn't it he didn't
practice it enough apparently on his on
his uh his car rides from New Jersey to
Pennsylvania and his plane rides from
New Jersey to Pennsylvania he really
should have practiced that more than
trying to Hawk
herbal supplements that
he was making profit off of
that's another thing that it's very
weird he's talking about well I didn't I
didn't make profit see I did they were
commercials well look
it's some in some instance in media you
have the ability
to gatekeep who is sponsoring your show
almost every single bit of the time not
all the time but 99 of the time this is
the thing that happens it's actually
that the entire the entire process of
when you're selecting sponsors for media
is the media
actually says what is the sponsor and
the sponsor says who is this media like
it's a thing that happens
and sponsorships for media that's
exactly how it works he knows that
now
the craziest part is the moderators in
that debate [ __ ] sucked they were
horrible horrible absolutely horrible
and I commend
uh John fetterman for even even
attempting to go on stage
um obviously John fetterman had some
auditory issues from his stroke everyone
knows how Strokes work
that people for sometimes several years
maybe the rest of their life have
auditory
problems
with certain Strokes
this stroke damn near killed this dude
damn near killed him
[ __ ] got up on stage last night
and showed people Pennsylvania that he's
not gonna lay down and stop fighting for
them
I think that was the biggest part of the
debate the opening statement about the
elephant in the room
and him actually saying Hey look
yeah I had a stroke but I'm not I don't
give a [ __ ]
I don't care I'm gonna keep fighting for
you I'm Gonna Keep I'm gonna keep coming
at these [ __ ]
I'm not gonna stop
one tough son of a [ __ ] if you want to
know the truth
and really the media especially like Joe
Scarborough talking about how John
fetterman tripped over a few words
really come on have you ever heard of of
a [ __ ] fake cop down in Georgia who's
running for Senate
Herschel Walker who whips out a fake
[ __ ] badge
he's not a cop and he's pretending to be
one
he's running around at all his events
flashing this thing pretending to be a
cop
Absolute Total [ __ ] delusion
that just because you have a badge makes
you a law enforcement officer it's
really something it's really a sight to
see
it's really a sight to see that the
media is focused on John fetterman who
had a stroke who has auditory issues
from that stroke having auditory issues
on the stage last night no not a not
really not really a peep
about Herschel Walker flashing a fake
badge
I mean if we're going to talk about if
we're going to talk about brain injury
and how serious and how serious we are
about brain injury then maybe we need to
have the discussion fine by me I mean
it's a little late it's October 26th
and the fascists are knocking at the
front door
so what I mean it's a little late now
but there is something you can do
there is something you can certainly do
which a lot of people are doing as we
speak right now
they're making their voice heard with
their vote
and you know I don't pile you up with
numbers and statistics
because I don't believe that that does
anyone any good
and I think the polls are absolutely
[ __ ] trash and you can't listen to
them and again
if a poll makes you feel good about
voting yeah believe it fine whatever if
we're going to live in a world of
delusion we might as well live in a
world of delusion that absolutely can
eradicate fascism from our government we
can't really keep fascism folks we can't
get rid of an idea you're not going to
be able to get rid of an idea
yeah
just like they can't get rid of our
ideas
but there is one thing that you can do
or cannot do
you can
put ideas into power
you can put policy makers in power with
those ideas
so my question is this if John vetterman
trips over a few words would you rather
have him tripping over a few words with
his ideas
in power
or the or the person from New Jersey who
has dual citizenship with turkey
who is a [ __ ] snake oil salesman
a carpetbagger who knows nothing about
Pennsylvania
only the fact that Donald Trump wanted
him to run to endorse him
that's it who do you think's gonna own
this [ __ ]
and then ask yourself a question who
who's gonna own John fetterman
what the lgbtq community
because he he believes in equity and
equality oh boy radical tight [ __ ]
stuff he wants to make sure
pennsylvanians don't go broke because of
a medical bill ah radical [ __ ] stuff
he wants to make sure that
pennsylvanians
receive a decent wage for the labor that
they trade ah radical [ __ ] stuff
socialism get the [ __ ] out of here with
that nonsense
name it odds once your mayor to tell you
rather you can have [ __ ] abortion or
not
that that my friends maybe might want to
give you some thought if you're in
Pennsylvania today and really if you're
if you're anywhere in this country
because you should be yelling and
screaming about this you should be
talking to people about this
forget about what words fetterman
stumbled over
let's talk about the words that Dr Oz
said out loud and didn't stumble over
that's the direction that's the aim [ __ ]
these [ __ ]
it's enough of this garbage we are not
we are not going to lay down and let our
democracy be taken over by a bunch of
nincompoop Nazis it is not going to
happen
and we must act like it this defeatist
attitude this both side [ __ ] there is no
both sides to this and we do not need to
be defeatist
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
we will lean all the way the hell into
our democracy
and we will not stop
I don't even give a [ __ ] if they take
the house I'm not gonna stop
I'm not going to stop talking I'm not
going to stop saying what the [ __ ] I
want to say I don't give a [ __ ]
it's way too important to me and I know
it's important to you the best audience
in the entire world here at the Tony
Michaels podcast
you are the greatest audience
and the reason why is because you give
no [ __ ]
the only thing that matters right now in
this moment in history is to save our
democracy
because we must keep this Republic we
must keep it
and it is up to us to do that
and yelling and screaming it works
I know it doesn't feel like it sometimes
but it works people are hearing us
people are scared hell they're even
attacking me
so good [ __ ] them let them attack us let
them go after us let them
let them say that we're secret agents of
the CIA which you know I'm not even I'm
not going to confirm or deny anything on
the show today but I have a super secret
guest today you're not gonna believe the
guest I have today oh my God we are
definitely gonna out the elephant in the
room we are going to expose this
information of who we really are
it's gonna be great today there's gonna
be a bunch a bunch of reveals today all
the people out there looking for reveals
today boy you are gonna wanna stay tuned
because at the bottom of this hour as we
do in them in the B Block after my
30-minute rant we are going to make big
reveals big secrets are gonna be
uncovered so stay tuned stay in the chat
don't go anywhere you know who you are
oh my god oh it's gonna be a fun day
it's hump day everybody and we got we
got less than two weeks now to close on
these [ __ ] that's right less
than two weeks to close this [ __ ] down
pack them up and get them [ __ ] out of
here
get them crawling back underneath their
[ __ ] rocks like that goddamn Nazi
canvasser that works for Marco Rubio
they thought that was real cute that
they were gonna accuse people of beating
up one of their canvassers when he's a
Nazi
he's a white supremacist
[ __ ] people out there thinking you're
defending Republicans still you're a you
are dumb [ __ ] you are defending
Nazis white supremacists domestic
terrorists these people sitting
criminally intimidating people at polls
they don't know it yet but they're
probably already under criminal
investigation trust me I got some I got
some secret tips with our government I
mean we're just on the inside let me
tell you about it here at the Tony
Michaels podcast boy we're connected
to the Deep State baby
oh boy I just I got I got something and
I I gotta share today
and uh someone's gonna join me to
to do this reveal because it is a huge
reveal of us of a huge secret that has
been that has been outed on the internet
um in recent days and this person is
going to help us tell the story of this
information that uh that has been outed
on the internet uh in recent days it's
uh boy it's uh
it really is quite it really is quite
the conspiracy but we'll get to the
bottom of that we'll get to the bottom
of that so stay tuned don't go anywhere
we'll get to that to the bottom of the
hour
uh let's see what else what else has
been happening in the news
um you know again this fetterman thing I
can smoke this out and I can really dunk
on on Joe Scarborough
um he's such a piece of garbage
but you have these fascist [ __ ] these
cry babies they're just whiny little
[ __ ]
like the Nazi down in
Florida canvassing for Marco Rubio who
got beat up because he's a fascist a
white supremacist that's I mean man you
know listen I'm not I'm not um for
violence but let me tell you something
if you're running around trying to stoke
violence
it that just may be what happens I mean
you just gotta because look when you put
people's lives at risk
it's not going to go well for you just
like the the Supreme Court Justices put
women's lives at risk in this country
and Alito oh they took away Rats from
women who put their lives at risk for
medical procedures
oh boy and he's real upset he's real
upset
that the Supreme Court Justices are
being threatened he threatened my ass
[ __ ] out of here with that nonsense as
if any decision that the Supreme Court
has ever made of this magnitude hasn't
brought threats
look there's crazy [ __ ] out
there trust me I know Gabe Sanchez is
gonna probably talk today about some
crazy [ __ ] that have been up in
his [ __ ]
that's another part of the reveal that
we have today
saying some crazy ass [ __ ]
it's it's it's it's it's the [ __ ]
it's the time folk folks
and Justice Alito crying about the
decision he made not to protect women's
rights and women's lives and now he's
crying because people are sending him
mean messages
and saying mean things about him
is really rich
really is it's kind of I don't know what
would Ted Cruz call Ted Cruz call it
elitist
[ __ ] out of here with that nonsense your
Supreme Court Justice
you know the consequences of your
decisions you know the consequences of
your actions and if you don't Alito then
[ __ ] resign
resign
it's not for this garbage we we do not
have to sit here and placate to these
[ __ ] we do not have to be nice
to them
they tried to steal our democracy away
from us
they came to the Capitol
planning
to overthrow our government just go look
at the Stuart Rhodes trial
credible threats
not just to Democrats
but to the vice president of the United
States there were credible threats
they knew it
the Republican Vice President of the
United States Donald Trump's running
mate
there was credible threats not just
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
folks they don't give a [ __ ] about
anything but unadulterated power and to
tell you what the [ __ ] you can do and
what you can believe
that's their goal that's their mission
the entire thing
the whole [ __ ] that's what it's
about
is to control you
what you do what you say what you think
their cancer culture they the right it
was born in them
where do you think the [ __ ] cancer
culture came from
people like oh there's no cancer culture
[ __ ] there isn't it's all on their side
every [ __ ] last one of them want to
cancel me they want to cancel you they
they want to cancel your ability to have
a private conversation with your [ __ ]
doctor Dr Oz wants to cancel that he
wants to make sure the mayor's in the
room with you the councilman's in the
room with you what are we gonna hold
[ __ ] City Council meetings
and vote rather women can get medical
procedures or not
folks doubt that just doubt that for a
minute
just doubt that for a minute
you don't think it's serious well
I'm here to tell you it's dead serious
and Justice Alito yes we do get really
angry and really mad and we're probably
gonna go stand in line and vote and
we're probably going to say mean [ __ ]
about your dumb ass when you [ __ ] put
women's lives at risk and take away
their constitutional rights [ __ ]
we are gonna get mean we're gonna say
mean things
it's not gonna be it's not gonna be
pretty when you make decisions to take
away people's rights when you're
supposed to be defending them you're a
Supreme Court Justice [ __ ]
so yeah we're gonna say mean [ __ ]
yeah we're gonna say [ __ ] that you don't
like to hear
because you are making the ultimate
the ultimate transgression against your
oath
is to protect the Constitution and
protect those rights of people
so [ __ ] you you can go to you [ __ ] all
the way off and I hope I hope eventually
you Thomas you're all gone Kavanaugh uh
I I hope we I hope we can impeach and
get rid of every [ __ ] one of you
every one of you we we should just
impeach you we win if we win the house
and we win the Senate we should just
impeach you and get rid of your dumb
asses we can do that spring core Justice
did you know that
since you don't want to be a Supreme
Court Justice anymore Alito maybe we'll
just impeach you and get rid of you
I don't know maybe it's a thing I mean
they're talking about impeaching peach
peach and peach peach peach why not [ __ ]
it let's just do that
we'll just make the next goddamn house
the next house about not the people not
helping the people in this country but
impeaching Supreme Court Justices how do
you like that Alito
that sounds like a right-wing thing that
they like to do they don't want to help
the people they don't want to actually
do government they don't want to have
anything to do with policy
they just want to they want to they want
here's what they want to do they want to
shut down the government
they want impeach Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris and make sure to investigate
Hunter Biden's laptop as if any of that
[ __ ] makes sense
so yeah us on the left are really super
pissed that you took away rights from
our sisters our mothers our daughters
our wives our friends our colleagues
yeah we're really super [ __ ] pissed
Alito we're really [ __ ] pissed and
we're gonna see some really mean [ __ ]
about you because you are a pile of [ __ ]
that's what we're gonna do and we're not
gonna and we have the right to do it
because it's our democracy
until we don't and let me tell you even
if they take away the right for me to
yell and scream I'm still gonna yell and
scream I don't give a [ __ ]
because that's what's gonna happen if
you don't get out and engage in your
democracy
that's what they want that's what
alito's saying
he's saying that he if he had a case in
front of him he would make sure that you
couldn't say mean [ __ ] about him
it's what he's saying he's projecting it
it's all projection from these fascists
all of it
they don't care about Equity they don't
care about equality they don't give a
[ __ ] about our constitution they don't
give two shits
it's up to us to protect it
when he said it's a republic
if you can keep it he was talking about
us not them not the [ __ ] Supreme
Court
not congress not the Senate us the
people because it is us
our democracy is We the People
listen to the words
it's time we get off our ass
and we lean in and we engage in our
democracy
full-throated not we will not stop
relentless
because they're not they're not gonna
stop
they're at the front door beating down
the door the fascists are here folks
Marco Rubio had a Nazi canvassing for
him
let me say that again Marco Rubio
had a Nazi
canvassing for him
you want me to I'll say it again Marco
Rubio had a Nazi canvassing for him
they're here it's the threat is now
they're right right now not not two
years from now at 2024 not the election
after that
not decide who's what we're going to do
when the next president comes no it's
right now
they're out canvassing for these
candidates who everyone assumed was just
a typical old Republican Marco Rubio
Little Marco just a typical Republican
nope
he has brown shirts
canvassing for him
and we know that now
because he's the one who was like oh my
canvasser got beat up
foreign
so what are you going to do about it
that's the question what are you going
to do about it someone text me yesterday
and said hey how do you feel about the
midterms
that's what they text me good friend of
mine
and I told him I said well I feel much
better than you do I'm sure
and he's kind of a pessimist I said you
need to be optimistic here this
defeatist attitude is not going to win
an election you have to project your
optimism you have to lean into democracy
we cannot be defeatist
we have to be confident about this so
confident that you are going to go vote
no matter what and you are going to find
three people to encourage them to vote
no matter what and encourage them to
find three more people
to vote no matter what and incur those
three find three to encourage three more
to vote no matter what
we're less than two weeks away folks
from the most important election of our
democracy's lifetime
it's here it's now some people don't see
this as the most important election they
laugh that off ah no big deal
it's a huge deal
and if we win this one it's not the last
one that we have to win we have to keep
pushing hard for democracy who gives a
[ __ ] about the party at this point who
gives a [ __ ] yes does Democrats and
democracy sound the same sure
but at this point we only have one
political party that is honestly
has gives two shits about policy one
government two and actually actually
making sure that our democracy is safe
from authoritarianism
I don't know if you watch the Jon
Stewart interview
with the attorney general in Arizona
it's brilliant brilliant and I can't
show it
because they'll give me a copyright
strike
so look at me a copyright striking out
take it out of the show anyways
but it's absolutely brilliant the clip I
guess it's going to be aired this Friday
a full the full interview
and the Republican the sitting
Republican attorney general from Arizona
will not just say Donald Trump [ __ ]
lost and he's lying
he says it right he kind of says it but
he doesn't say it
and that kind of capitulation is what is
going to get us to a fascist state
and the Nazis know it that's why they're
on these campaigns canvassing
most of the time they hide underneath
their rocks
because they don't want to be exposed as
Nazis
because it's really I mean it's not like
a you know
it's not like a good thing to be exposed
as that's why they keep covering their
faces this Patriot front but this guy
this dumb Buck was in Charlottesville
with a mask off
because they thought president Trump
would save them then their their their
Mussolini Jesus would save them
it's real take it seriously and I'm dead
serious when I say
make sure you encourage three people and
get them to encourage three people you
can't force someone to vote you can't
intimidate someone into voting that's
not how it works in a democracy
but you can encourage them tell them the
stakes
they'll see it they'll see it and let
them go vote maybe they'll maybe they'll
vote for the candidate you want them to
maybe they won't that's their right
that's the point what I want is I wish
everyone who was eligible to vote in
this election went and cast their ballot
so we could really see where the country
stands
that's what I want more than anything
that's why I say we must encourage
everyone every single person to go vote
I want I personally want to know
how bad this is this disease I think
it's I think it's a fraud I think the
idea that the majority there's a big
huge majority in this country that
supports this garbage is a fraud it's
always been a fraud
even the people who show up at the Nazi
are excuse me Trump rallies everybody we
have a special guest we have a special
reveal coming at the bottom of the hour
and we are at the bottom of the hour
so don't forget don't forget to to hit
that subscribe button
here on the YouTube channel
you're not going to want to miss this
reveal it's a huge reveal I promise you
it's coming people been looking for this
reveal for days
um also follow us at Tony Michaels pod
on Twitter I'm sure this is going to end
up on Twitter somewhere also download
every single episode including this one
share this reveal with all your friends
and if you're on Facebook follow us on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels we
broadcast from the minus touch Facebook
page and my Facebook page I put a bunch
of uh memes over there they got curse
words in them so if you like memes with
cursing in it and come follow me on
Facebook do that everyone stick around I
got a really special guest here for a
big reveal that everyone has been on the
internet has been waiting for stick
around don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after these messages
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual party is not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around I've got a
very very important guess for a reveal
that the entire internet has been
waiting for and this is big huge news
unveil a secret agent of the government
some government secrets are about to be
had here uh here on the Tony Michaels
podcast listen yesterday was Tuesday
and which normally is Taco Tuesday in
Texas ball Tuesday but Texas Paul was
traveling
but I found out some information on the
internet yesterday that you're not going
to believe
you are not going to believe the
information I found out now I already
knew this because you know the cabal and
all
but I want to make a big reveal here
today on the Tony Michaels podcast
because Texas ball has always wore his
cowboy hat
um in true Texas fashion and he's been
to the cussing Pond but he went to the
actual deep State over this week he
actually went to the Deep State now the
headquarters of the deep State he went
to the White House in DC as everyone
knows now Texas Paul couldn't join us
yesterday and I I think it's him today
but
it seems to be his real identity
um Texas Paul how are you how are you
this morning Texas ball
how are you sir
hello I'm trying I'm trying to figure
out is this a uh
Orlando Ortiz oh okay
okay well you see the problem is is that
yeah
Tony yeah it's me it's me Texas ball
you're on the Tony Michaels podcast
oh did you think did you think this was
some kind of thing
yeah okay yeah he must have had he must
have thought that this was a uh one of
those CIA meetings now I don't know if
you heard
um but there has been some information
been released on the internet that Texas
Paul and his cohorts that went to
Washington are secret agents of the CIA
they're all over Twitter apparently
oh yeah let's see let's see oh there we
go [ __ ] okay so much for working for the
CIA I know I know it's uh it's that
sweet paycheck is gone now oh so so damn
it you think you'll lose your position
at the CIA now that you've been revealed
is that what you're saying
well you know my most you know my best
cover or you know Orlando Ortiz down in
you know Orlando Orlando
so you're not dead anymore well there
goes that identity
there goes that damn I tell you what it
is it is something it is something to um
to watch uh CR CIA operatives right out
in the open on Twitter it really is
funny especially when they especially
when they go to their own cussing ponds
Texas Paul
um all joking aside and I'm gonna show
the video here of um of I think you'd
call her alicon or something like that
uh he's she's your arch nemesis now on
the internet apparently now [ __ ] I
call her dumbass Barbie oh dumbass
Barbie initial that's the official
handle well before I do that I want to
ask you about your trip to DC your deep
State trip to DC I watched a video where
you were standing by one of the biggest
cussing ponds that you've ever been in
front of what did you make oh yeah
reflection pool what did you make of
that
I am I am telling you Tony
um
just just to get real for a second
and I went to the Capitol and I went to
the you know we walked by the reflection
pool and and on the way up there
and man you cannot walk into the capitol
without your heart just I
there there aren't words I can say to
anybody
the feeling you get as an American when
you walk in the capital that building is
magical
it is I mean it it just hits you like
you wouldn't believe the patriotism the
amount of joy that fuels your heart when
you love this country you know and it
just
for about the first you know and I
walked around thinking Capitol Police
and just just for saving our democracy
and I tell you man it was
you when you start making your way
through and you see Nancy Pelosi's
office there and you just and you think
about the what they did in that building
the amount of anger that I walked out of
there with I couldn't even I couldn't
even I was going to do a bit outside I
was going to do a video outside I
couldn't do it couldn't I was so angry I
was so pissed off
you that they would do that
to our capital and you don't I can't I'm
at a loss for words to explain to you
how it feels when you walk outside and
you think back to January 6th and the
[ __ ] they did I mean let alone breaking
a window was bad enough but when you put
your hands on that building and you feel
it
[ __ ] these [ __ ] I will hate
these [ __ ] till the day I die
I just
you can't there are just not words for
it Tony there just aren't words for it
I just
this is your chance okay they wanted to
give us a giant [ __ ] you on January 6
and say
[ __ ] you we're gonna do whatever this is
your chance early early voting is going
on right now
you want to give them a [ __ ] you
go down to the voting booth and vote
every last goddamn Republican out of
office
every last one of those [ __ ]
those traitors sons of [ __ ] that are
still to this day not [ __ ] decrying
with the [ __ ] that happened I'm telling
you
every American should have to go put
their hands on that building
and just feel what it feels like I mean
it's
it's the beacon of our democracy
I'm telling you have we been there had
we been there they'd have got what they
wanted they'd have got that Civil War
they wanted
they would have I that's that's all that
could go through my mind was
I am glad in talking to the Capitol
Police the cool heads that they kept
just not because if anybody had opened
fire everybody's like why didn't they
shoot him why didn't they shoot him
and every Capitol Police you policeman
you talked to says if we would have
opened fire we knew we were out gunned
we knew what was in the crowd this isn't
a matter of you know we knew the January
6th coverage we know what kind of
Firepower they brought to the Capitol
I mean they were this damn close if
Ashley Babbitt had gotten her hand to
the lock on that door
we would not have a country right now we
would be in a full-on shooting Civil War
right now we would
because they're not taking my democracy
that's that's what they don't understand
they're not taking women's rights away
my mother my grandmother my sisters
fought too damn hard for those rights
for them to take them away from my
daughters and my granddaughters that's
not happening
they're not taking our democracy away
that's not happening the only argument
left to have is how much pain
are Republicans going to go through
before they realize that's not happening
that's it that's the last argument right
there and this is where you start you go
to the voting booth and you vote those
[ __ ] out
period
I couldn't agree with you uh more in
Texas Paul I think it's um we are up
against
um a fascist state if we don't do
something and I I know Gabe agrees with
that wholeheartedly as well this is the
most important election of our
democracy's life and and as soon as it's
counted as soon as those ballots are
cast and we must bring the statement
like Texas Paul is saying if we don't
show them what we mean now we may have
to show them what we mean in the future
because we are not going to give away
our democracy we're not going to give
away our rights it is not something that
is going to happen I don't believe
Americans are going to do that I agree
with you
um
Gabe did you have anything you wanted to
add there
no I think it's spot on I mean uh
these people are
you know I mean I don't want to remove
the the the label of being an American
but that these people are are acting not
in the best interest of our country they
are working against us I mean I I
literally got a message yesterday just
to give context I literally got a
message yesterday of of some random dude
who I thought at first was racist and
then I got worse he sent me a message
and said um
he said uh take your ass back across the
border if you don't like this country
right so clearly this guy's been
watching this show right so I'm truly
watching some I guarantee because he
then went later I mean I can you know I
could show the image if I really want uh
went in more doubled down and said you
know you saw what they did on January
6th you saw this uprising of white
people like be grateful don't you know
if it weren't for the white man I mean
like literally this message says uh you
need to thank a white man today he is
the reason you have a civilized society
the new right will come to power
ultimately remove You by will or by foes
and the factus or keep [ __ ] around
and find out but hey when you uh when
your world is over don't think I didn't
tell you exactly what is about to happen
here
these are the people
that want other facets other white
supremacists in power these are these
are messages I get on a daily basis from
these people these are the ones who come
through try to storm overthrow the
capital so that they can you know put
their their golden
shower Jesus in power
and that is who they want and that is
the type of people that are that that
that frustrate me right I mean I hate
these people for the things that they
say to me and I hate these people for
the things that they say to other people
and especially what they stand for and
again you know even when you bring up
something like Marco Rubio we talked
about this yesterday the one thing I
want to add to this and re-emphasize is
these people will not you know die for
that person they will die for the
ideology that that person represents
right so no one's no one's out here
fighting over Marco Rubio they're
fighting over what Marco Rubio is
allowing to happen right those are the
examples of what's happening and these
are the people
that that try to you know
like Ashley Babbitt they they want to
overthrow the government to run it how
they want to be which is I'm a white
person and no one else has the rights as
I do and I want to keep this again this
golden shower Jesus in power so
I don't know that's that's what I want
to say on that I I wholeheartedly agree
with you and I can only imagine what it
would have been like to actually be
there at the Capitol and touch the stone
on that building and and understand what
was at stake and what still is at stake
right because it wasn't just January 6th
right this is something that they are
going to continue to attempt in the
future whether it's through physical or
other political means well Texas Paul
let me ask you because
um gay breaks up a good point that in
private
these white supremacists are saying
exactly what they're not saying in
public they're like oh January 6th it's
overblown it was tourist event you know
all of them Ron Johnson Marco Rubio
Marco Rubio was spotted yesterday which
is a rare appearance talking about how
January 6th it's all a scam but these
the white supremacists out there that
that are are saying the stuff like Gabe
just said in his DM those things that's
how they that's how the masses of the
white supremacists really feel now it's
a it's a low percentage of this country
it's a large group of people numbers
wise but it's a low percentage but
they're getting other people like I
don't know Republicans to do their
bidding here in their slow walk to
Fascism to have this wet dream of of
Exterminating people
well let me let me clear something up
Marco Rubio doesn't consider himself
Hispanic he doesn't he considers himself
White
he does that that that's it period I
mean you need to get that clear through
your head people will be confused how
can a guy but with the last name of
Rubio uh so have a full-on [ __ ] Nazi
canvassing form because Marco Rubio is a
white supremacist if there are nine
people sitting at a table
and a Nazi sits down
and they all keep doing going on and you
know everything's all good there are 10
Nazis sitting at that [ __ ] table
I am Telling You Marco Rubio is a
[ __ ] white supremacist and that piece
of [ __ ] that got his ass handed to him
in Hialeah got his ass handed to him
because he was out [ __ ] canvassing as
a goddamn white supremacist in Hialeah
Hialeah is a I think it's uh 98 Hispanic
town
I mean it's almost 100 Hispanic it
really is now a lot of them are like
Marco Rubio they don't think that
they're Hispanic they think they're
white
um I got news for you when all of this
shakes out and uh I I just came from the
Hollis College Museum folks
um they may use Marco Rubio in the
beginning but once those white
supremacists have their fascist State
Marco Rubio is a dead man
just like everybody else they will come
for him
they will come for him he doesn't know
it but they will I hate to be
harsh like that and it's not an ounce of
hyperbole I am telling you once they're
done with Marco Rubio once they have
their fascist State Marco Rubio is out
of there he will be in the camps with
everybody else
and I don't I don't really understand
this I'm not Hispanic I'm white thing
but I'm telling you these these white
supremacist sons of [ __ ] don't think
like you do they don't they'll use you
they'll use this [ __ ] con confederate
[ __ ] that got his ass beat and
highlighted and you know Marco Rubio's
whining like a little [ __ ] about how oh
they beat up my God because he was a
republican no they didn't they beat up
your guy because he was canvassing as a
[ __ ] white supremacist what do you
think he was saying to people when he
was knocking on their doors you think he
was saying that oh we got to get
together and we've got great ideas and
we got no that [ __ ] is a white
supremacist they all talk the same
and it doesn't matter if they're
confused White supremacists because
you know as I walked through the
Holocaust Museum what hit me
the first thing that hit me and let me
ask you a question guys both you take a
wild guess what percentage of Germany do
you think was Jewish
when the Nazis took power
wild guess anybody in the comments
30 percent
18.
point eight eight
wait wait wait wait no not point eight
you mean 88 right not point eight no I
mean points you're confirming eight
eight percent of the population in
Germany was Jewish
they were hard working now see if that
doesn't sound familiar they were hard
working
they were very family oriented they were
very Community oriented
their religion was very important to
them they worked their asses off to
become successful and what does that
sound like to you did they say did they
come did they come from somewhere else
to Germany were they were they migrants
from somewhere else to Germany
many were many were it does kind of
sound familiar yeah and if you can't
follow the parody between what these
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] Republicans are
doing with immigrants today and what the
Nazis did with Germany
you're you're an idiot you need to wake
up you need to go down to the Holocaust
Museum because I'm telling you they take
you up to the top floor and you work
your way down and the top floor is the
Nazi rise to power and the first thing
that hit me was that number right there
and then I turned a corner and I saw a
pile of books and you know what I saw in
that pile of books what's that
ungerman books
books that made them uncomfortable Oh
you mean you mean like like told them
different history that they don't want
to hear
yeah you know like uh you know like like
that made their kids feel bad for being
German you know I mean you know the kind
of thing that you hear in your local
[ __ ] school board meeting this sounds
familiar it really does sound familiar
Texas Paul that's exactly what they did
that's they went to the local [ __ ]
schools and they took the books out that
made them feel uncomfortable the ones
that didn't say Germany first man
Germany first
huh that sounds familiar and they burned
them and they burned them now what the
hell's going on now what's going on now
and and they're they're doing the exact
same things they had to lie about the
Jews in Germany they had to lie about
them they had to if you could make a man
believe absurd absurdities you can make
a man commit atrocities so they lied to
people about the Jews in Germany they
did they were just good-hearted people
that loved their families they were a
tight-knit community and they were a
small number
so you could attack them they were the
other that you could attack and they do
the same thing with immigrants here and
it's the exact same thing
and believe me Marco Rubio looked me in
the [ __ ] eye you are not in the club
I know
I'm as white as it [ __ ] gets if I
pull my sleeve I'm [ __ ] clear people
I'm not white I'm [ __ ] clear I know
who they let in the [ __ ] club and
you're not in it Marco Rubio you're a
[ __ ] tool that's what you are to
these people you're a tool
every one of you down in Florida who
thinks that the Cuban Community down in
Florida thinks the Republicans love them
they do not you will end up in a [ __ ]
camp in the middle of a Florida swamp so
goddamn fast the minute that they have
their fascist government your head is
going to spin your head is going to
[ __ ] spin you will be the first
people they attack
and the only difference is going to be
what emblem they paint on your goddamn
door the goddamn door of your business
the goddamn door of your house or they
make you wearing your goddamn chest
that's the only [ __ ] difference
and if you don't believe it you're an
idiot because these people speak to me
freely when they don't know who I am
because I walk around town and I don't
have my Texas Paul shirt on and these
[ __ ] don't follow me they don't
know who I am
and they say the most goddamnest thing
you've ever heard Gabe when you read to
me what that sunbit said to you I was
like yep that's exactly what you're
saying that's exactly what they say
be grateful to the white man boy I tell
you what because it's if it wasn't for
the white man this would be goddamn
barbarity going on because they believe
that about people of color let me let me
let me tell you something to blow your
[ __ ] mind
they teach you about the Alamo here in
Texas that's a big [ __ ] deal they
teach it around the country about the
Alamo do you know who the good guys were
in the Alamo at the Alamo the battle at
the Battle of the [ __ ] Alamo who was
the good guys it's the [ __ ] people
that were outside the Alamo were the
[ __ ] good guys you know why you know
why Santa Ana was there do you know why
General Santa Ana was at the [ __ ]
Alamo because he told those white
[ __ ] there will not be slave
trade in the state of Texas you can come
live here and take care of my Indian
problem kill all the Indians you want
but you will not own slaves and they
kept having slaves in Texas so he said
enough is enough and he marched North
and the fight was on
the people inside the Alamo were
fighting to preserve slavery
not an exaggeration not a [ __ ] joke
that's the truth people they don't teach
you that in high school and they want to
keep
them from teaching you that in high
school
because they don't want that that's what
this fight is about that's right they
don't want the white man to be tarnished
by by slavery they don't want them to be
turned by slavery that's why that's why
the Civil War wasn't about slavery Texas
well it wasn't about slavery
and you know the most [ __ ] up part
about it is I am a white man I am not
tarnished by slavery
why because I can look at it and say
that was [ __ ] up right don't do that
never allow that to happen again
these [ __ ] think about that put that
in your head for a second if you're the
person that is bothered
by someone saying white folks
committed slavery in the South I mean
they they they were brutal General Lee
the guy they love to worship used to
whip his slaves and then brine them and
if you don't know what that means go
look it up that's [ __ ] horrific
if you are a person that that hurts your
soul for that to be said you're on the
[ __ ] wrong side of History
because that doesn't bother me in the
slightest Robert E Lee was a [ __ ]
dick
I don't own him
my people my people were fighting on the
other [ __ ] side I'm not even kidding
my people were on the other side I live
in Texas now but we weren't here then
my Irish and German ancestors were
[ __ ] up north man
they were
I can track my Heritage way the [ __ ]
back to like 1820 and we were up north
then my people were wearing the blue
suits can I tell you good story Texas
Paul uh yeah actually I actually had
relatives
um because they lived in Central
Missouri now if anyone knows about
Missouri it was a split State and it's
kind of weird because the north was for
the South and the South was kind of for
the north
um I know that sounds weird but it's
geography and because of where you can
actually plant
um you know crop in Missouri because
anything above the Missouri River is
actually cropland anything below it is
the basically the Ozark Mountain
Foothills but here's the thing is in my
family even
we traced back history we had we had
Confederates and Union all in the same
family
um it was split that that heavy and so
you don't you you don't own what your
ancestors did you don't own it but you
can be honest about it you can tell the
truth that yeah of course I had I had a
con I had a Confederates in my family I
have people who fought for the Union in
my family but that war that war
specifically was fought about slavery
and the state's rights to own slaves
just like what the we can be honest
about the second world war and what's
going on right now in our country just
what you said about what Nazi Germany
did and didn't do what their goals were
what the slow march to Fascism was we
can be honest about that we don't have
to lie about it we don't have to we
don't have to be be cognizant of white
supremacist feelings we do not have to
do that we do not have to tolerate
intolerance and it is getting more and
more intolerable to to the intolerance
is getting more and more intolerable
because of the [ __ ] they're saying and
how far they're going just look in the
and get Gabe can I put this up here yeah
yeah here's the here's the graphic here
from the um the person that got in his
DMS and I've read this whole thing and
it's not just the words that are
underlined that are vile those are just
the most vile underlined words
um but it is it is absolutely disgusting
what this person said to Gabe in the DM
but here's the thing folks
just what Texas Paul said
just what Texas Paul said
they're all believing this they're all
believing this and the people that
they're using like Marco Rubio and
Herschel Walker Candace Owens they are
tools in that effort they are tools in
that effort of white supremacy because
here's the thing if they can convince
people who have a last name like Gabe
that whites are Supreme and they're
Superior and they somehow inherently
possess more rights over this country
over this land
then we're done we're finished we're
finished and they know that they [ __ ]
know it Texas Paul you know you know it
and I know they know it I I I I I don't
mean to sound like a broken record I
don't
but LBJ said it he said it out loud so
everybody would learn for it to learn
from it and take it to heart if you tell
the lowest white man that he is better
than the highest black man
submit person of color Asian Hispanic
whatever
you do not have to pick his pockets he
will turn his pockets out for you
that has to be addressed Tony I've said
it before we've got to clean up our own
[ __ ] backyard first
these [ __ ]
are are they're broken they're [ __ ]
brain dead their idiotic dumb stupid
scared weak little sons of [ __ ]
you know if you are really afraid that
Hispanics are going to come in through
our Southern border and replace you
you're a [ __ ] idiot
you're a [ __ ] idiot
you really are you're gonna come here
you know what's funny about that and
you're bringing up the Alamo and me and
Gabe talked about it yesterday at the
southern border quote unquote the actual
Southern border was much more North much
more North many many years ago and
really
um we replaced those people in parts of
those territories where we took and
stole their land
unlike what Ron DeSantis wants to
believe is a [ __ ] lie again a white
supremacist lie yes Mexico Mexico came
all the way up into California dummies
and we stole it from them we the white
man stole it from them we replaced them
that is what happened and you don't you
don't have you don't have to feel sorry
for it you don't have to feel guilt for
it and like Texas Paul said if you do
that's a you problem that's a [ __ ]
you problem that you don't like the
truth that is not that is not the truce
problem that is not what is Real's
problem
it does the actual truth doesn't give a
[ __ ]
rather you like it or not it doesn't
give a [ __ ] whether you believe it or
not and if you don't believe it that's a
you problem white dude especially Jeremy
here in the comments I see him I wanna
yeah there's a we just for Texas Paul to
know we got this one guy Jeremy Johnson
definitely a [ __ ] racist uh he I just
want to pull this comment up yeah uh
okay no
I'm not being a snowflake here's the
thing I I put that together to to shed
light on the types of things that I get
like I don't look 100 Hispanic here
right I'm feeling haven't you received
that kind of [ __ ] in your life oh
because your mom is white yeah my mom's
white my dad is Mexican here's the thing
Jeremy over here was asking me for my
papers yesterday to prove that I was
actually a citizen of this country to
prove that I was actually an American
did they give you papers in Chicago man
did they give you papers and I don't I
don't know I didn't I didn't write the
papers I had vaccination records I got
my school report I got uh my medical
checkup did you keep all your math
homework too did you keep those papers
when I got tested for ADHD I had those I
got them in the closet back there all of
those things I keep those are the only
papers I have right outside of my birth
certificate that says I was [ __ ] born
in this [ __ ] country but here's the
thing that Jeremy has a hard time on
understanding he doesn't like the fact
that his people right the white man that
he clearly aligns in with this person
from uh from uh Instagram and send me
those messages also Jeremy if you send
me those messages just own up to it now
man just say it now you [ __ ] I hope you
didn't kick him out I hope you didn't
kick him out because I yeah we don't
he's still here I mean that the fake
Gabe fake gay by the way he left fake
game left after you torched him after
you [ __ ] ripped him a new one yeah he
left he gone he's gone man he couldn't
handle let me let me clear let me let me
clear something up for Jeremy here okay
and this is why I say we need to clean
up our own backyard
was the land stolen
yeah we stole the [ __ ] out of that land
we did
that's the truth what do Indians want
you to do Native Americans first people
what do they what do they want you to
acknowledge that you [ __ ] stole it
okay we did
we did does that mean that you've got to
you today have to [ __ ] apologize for
it no because you didn't steal it
you weren't there that was a shitty
[ __ ] thing that happened and yes they
used to have a a city up in in Tony's
neck of the woods up in Missouri that
rivaled London yes they they want you to
know that they were not what's been
portrayed in [ __ ] Hollywood that's
what they're trying to tell you are they
trying to tell you you got to give the
[ __ ] country back no that's not going
to happen
I mean I'm I'm German and Irish people
you should see my history you know how
much of our land was [ __ ] stolen
all of it all of it
English History it's all stolen Land one
group after another stole it one group
after a [ __ ] another has stolen all
the land do you think the Slavs owned
Russia no they stole it
they stole it
if you can't study history and just
accept [ __ ] happens
and you've got to live with the people
that are here
except that the first people here
we're a hell of a culture
just do that Jeremy don't be a [ __ ] do
that
just accept that the people that came
over here didn't sit around and have
[ __ ] turkeys and and and stuffing on
Thanksgiving there was no Thanksgiving
to give because we were [ __ ] dicks
when we got here whoa whoa whoa whoa
wait a second are you telling me that
that the indigenous people who they were
killing with disease didn't sit down and
serve them turkey was stepping in it
that is why we have this day coming up
soon uh Texas Paul why white people sit
around and sing Kumbaya about how we
were great to the natives that don't you
know that don't you know you're hit
actually actually I will be honest with
you the people that came over here were
as dumb as these [ __ ] people that
followed Greg Locke they were the most
religious radicals you've ever seen in
your life and they were dying they were
[ __ ] dying man they were dying out
and the [ __ ] locals saved them the
first people saved their ass they showed
them how to farm what was growing here
they showed them how to gather what was
here and save their [ __ ] lives
and then and Jeremy can't even just
[ __ ] acknowledge that maybe he owes
an Indian a hug I keep calling the
minions up well that's you know from
when I was a kid maybe it was the first
person to hug maybe
some gratitude we talked about this
yesterday Texas Paul about language
right and and calling Jewish people Jews
because I I Michael Rappaport made a
video about it and I sent it to Gabe and
I was like hey am I off because I'm
white I'm a white dude I'm a white dude
I should not be going around telling
people of color what I can and cannot
call them I should be asking them and
maybe maybe when you ask someone and you
talk to them they'll talk to you
people of color not scary they're not
scary they're not I know you're scared
of them Jeremy but they're not scary
they're really not if you just talk to
them they're humans they'll tell you
even even if there's words that you want
to use about them they'll tell you about
those [ __ ] words they're not scared
of those words there is all kinds of
words I bet Gabe Sanchez has been called
in his life and he isn't scared of those
words but he'll talk to you about them
he'll talk to you about him he'll
actually have a conversation with you
about those words I had a conversation
with him about a word which is Jews and
we had a conversation
it was a private conversation we talked
about it yesterday on the air but that
is the thing is that I'm telling you
that the and I think you're exactly
right we have Texas Paul we have to we
have to take we have to undo our own
which is the white men in this country
and it is men I mean there are some
white women who buy into the misogyny
right they're they buy into this man is
superior white man is superior the white
supremacy thing so they're included in
that but the problem the problem
specifically is white supremacy and it's
it's white dudes who believe it it's
white dudes who believe it that is the
problem we have to take care of this
problem and honestly Texas Paul you
saying the word Indians
is exactly is exactly what we're talking
about that's exactly what we're talking
about the things that we have to undo in
this society and it's not because that
word is bad it's because it's a lie it's
a [ __ ] lie they weren't in India they
weren't in India they're not indians
they are indigenous people to America
that is what they are and it's and to
call them to call them Indians is what
Hollywood wanted like you said earlier
and it's because and again it's not
because that word is bad it's because
it's a [ __ ] lie it's a total outright
lie and that's why and but but Texas
Paul when you when we were in school
because I I know you you have just a few
years on me
um but but even when I was in school
that's the word that was used that's the
words that anyone would use to describe
indigenous people and really up until
indigenous people said no you're not
going to describe us that way you're not
going to describe us with that [ __ ]
lie anymore it was only until then until
people realized hey maybe this maybe
this isn't a good idea to to describe
people that way and that is exactly a
good example Texas fall because I don't
think the audience is going to knock you
for saying that word but acknowledging
that that word exists because of that
that's what we need to take care of
and that's how weak these people are
right that's how weak they are you know
we need to put Gabe we need to put
Jeremy in our adopt a white boy program
oh yeah definitely yeah we do we do some
cookouts right he would he would benefit
greatly just from experiencing another
culture like there are so many times
when I've spoken to if I go to another
country or uh or even if I'm like at a
restaurant right
um
when I see someone from that culture
from that region respond to someone who
makes an attempt to speak their language
right not the Assumption like I speak
English so because I'm visiting you
should understand what I'm saying
even if it's the worst broken form it's
the attempt it's you actually attempting
to bridge a gap between two cultures two
types of people
and communicate right that shows that
you actually care enough to to to go 50
at least 50 even even if it means that
you can't really speak it and you know
every other word or whatever it might be
you're at least attempting
to bridge us together as a global
Community when you've got people like
Jeremy who say you only speak American
here in [ __ ] USA dumb [ __ ] like that
speak American you got I mean like dude
I've had people say oh man can't you
just speak American like are you that
[ __ ] dumb yeah that you don't
understand that's not how we talk to
people that's not what we say and at the
end of the day like my biggest issue is
that these people don't learn right they
assume that their way the white way is
the right way right and it's not and
they're afraid that change has been
happening and they are going to be left
behind you know to re they're going to
be they're gonna be held back a year and
a year and a year and a Year again to
redo that that class that they were in
right
they are afraid that while everyone else
is doing good and are doing well in
their life and progressing forward
they're Left Behind they're going to be
like when when we split off between uh I
forget that you know Homo sapiens versus
the other group right there was a there
was a point when one decided hey we're
gonna now do this instead and we will
survive and the other group decided to
fall off the face of the Earth right for
any flat earthers the the Earth is round
just so you know but what I will say is
that at the end of the day here the
thing that we should be doing right that
we we talk about in our Constitution
which is you know Pursuit of Happiness
Liberty Justice uh uh this American
dream that we've been we've been told
we should be able to progress yeah our
history and and our past is [ __ ] it's
a [ __ ] show it is terrible it is awful
let's call it what it is it is [ __ ]
vile but we are not defined by our past
we can work toward a better future
progress forward and be better to build
a more uh connected Community a more
aligned Society a more uh uh just group
of people who are aware right cognizant
not not stuck in their ways saying you
gotta speak American or whatever the
dumb [ __ ] excuses right whatever the
thing that I've received in this message
which we're saying I should be grateful
for the white man for the electricity
for the computer that I'm spreading my
propaganda on which I'm literally just
talking about
American values here and this other
person wants to attack me for it you
know you know what he you know what the
person in your DM doesn't know is the uh
he doesn't know that there's people of
color who invented a lot of [ __ ] to get
to the internet they don't they don't
see and that's and that's the problem
that's that's what I'm saying about the
lies Texas Paul is that the lie that we
were told when we were kids that you
call you Call indigenous people Indians
that's a lie that's a lie and it and it
dilutes you Jeremy it really does it
gets you in a position where you just
don't know the truth and that's where
they want you they want you dumb they
want you stupid they want you ignorant
so that they can use your hate and stoke
your fear as a tool for them just like
they did Marco Rubio just like they're
doing Herschel Walker the same way just
like they're doing that little Nazi
because apparently that Nazi is not a
white dude he thinks he's a white dude
he thinks he is I want though with get
canvasser I guess but you know that's
the same thing it's the same thing we're
talking about right Texas ball
yeah exactly and and what I'm trying to
communicate here to people like Jeremy
is how weak and scared you look
you know I mean you don't have to be
afraid
to to know Real History it pisses Jeremy
off that we tell him
don't call the first people Indians
because that just that's just part of
the [ __ ] that was an abuse and and
it it's a it's an insult don't
just call them what they're supposed to
he's so lazy weak and scared that he
that threatens him to have to what you
want me to learn first people
you want me to learn to say first people
or what kills me is is you know I always
tell the story about I've got a really
great friend of mine and and she was in
a Walmart with her mother and they were
speaking Spanish in this Karen [ __ ]
walked up to him we speak English in
this country and her mother turned
around her mother speaks seven [ __ ]
languages including English and in
perfect English told her would you
prefer I speak and broke into French and
then would you prefer I speak and broke
into Russian and printed you know what I
mean and it's like you ignorant [ __ ]
[ __ ]
Spanish is the easiest language on the
planet to learn it is way easier to
learn than English English is a hard
language to learn it is really do you
take a non-english speaker the way the
way everything is is broken down in a
sentence doesn't work that way in almost
any language on this planet I mean we're
a one-off man we're damn near one-off
Spanish is so easy
and they're scared of it they're like
you want me to learn something you know
I mean come on man this is easy the rest
of the world speaks multiple languages
they do because we get along with each
other and you know it's just Jeremy's
weak and scared they're all weak and
scared they they it it terrifies them
when that's why they say we they're
teaching CRT they're teaching CRT when
nobody's teaching [ __ ] CRT unless
you're in a law school course and even
then it's not even required it's it's
part of a particular course in law
school I mean critical race they're
they're like they want me to learn
critical race they're they're going to
teach my kids that stuff man it's
[ __ ] dude you know you know what
else is scared of anyone else Jeremy's
scared of because this is the other
white dude thing that's going around and
we talk about it with Matt Walsh they're
terrified absolutely terrified Texas
Paul that they would find a woman
attract active absolutely terrified that
they find a woman attractive and then
find out it wasn't that person wasn't
always a woman terrifies them terrifies
them that that defines them and oh boy I
can't I can't feel those feelings those
feelings are weird they feel weird so
and it's the same thing as they're not
willing to approach and talk to a person
of color because oh they're they're it
makes them feel weird makes them feel
you know oh it gives me weird feelings
and they're scared of those feelings
they're scared you know can I throw one
thing out there
could you imagine because let me tell
you this Enlightenment we're talking
about is not a normal state of humanity
it's not
it's not a normal State look at what
Russian soldiers are doing to Ukrainian
soldiers
in Ukraine and they're both Slavic
okay look at the abuse look at the
inhumanity that's going on the type of
Enlightenment we're talking about if we
could Embrace that and just be that
would literally make us
the greatest country on Earth
we would be the greatest people to have
ever lived because we're the only
experiment like this in the world French
people have French people and everybody
else
we don't do that
Gabe my buddy
is every bit the American I am
we're one of the only countries that do
that
imagine that think about that just let
it sink in how much [ __ ] greater we
would really be
if we just put that [ __ ] down that fear
that that racism that hatred that and
just accepted each other we would be the
first you know
the first people did that quite a bit
they literally I don't know if you know
this Tony but you're you're live near
some of one of the greatest cities that
was ever on
this planet
was a first people city that was about
the size of London
and it was a trading center where tribes
came in different tribes it wasn't all
owned by One Tribe I mean they came in
and they traded with one another they
were starting this but they didn't
finish it
we could be those people man
and to just let fear and bias and hate
and that stupid [ __ ] that they the
psychological game of telling Jeremy
he's better than Barack Obama when
Barack Obama went to [ __ ] law school
he's a constitutional scholar he's a
[ __ ] outstanding father
you know I mean he's an amazing human
being
but Jeremy Jeremy wants somebody to tell
Jeremy that he's better than Barack
Obama so Jeremy can feel better about
where he got in life why well you know
yeah well I mean that that's that's part
for the course Texas Paul I mean why
wouldn't why wouldn't we need to placate
to Jeremy's little sensitivities his
snowflake could I mean we really should
do that because you know to make him
feel good and him feel wanted because
that's his privilege and that's his
right to oppress the rights of other
people that is not Liberty that is not
what we're going to do we are not going
to tolerate intolerance we are not going
to placate to your little [ __ ] idea
we're not going to do it we're not going
to do it so much in fact so much in fact
that we are willing to join the Deep
state in the CIA Texas Paul did you hear
that you are a member of the CIA I don't
mean to skip topics here but we are
running out of time I really want to get
to this video you know I do
this is the reason why Texas ball came
on today instead of waiting till next
Tuesday is because of this video so you
did
video first or did she I think you did a
video on her video is that what it was
no I I actually I I have I have done
okay it started out this is a hateful
little [ __ ] I'm going to tell you
Allison Steinberg is a hateful little
[ __ ] she really is man she did a a a a
take where we first ran across each
other's path a hateful
greed about her little her little
Community was threatened because
one of the city I don't know who it was
the mayor whoever had a pride flag
flying down in in Huntington Beach
is this the same mayor that's going to
make decisions for women in their
abortions yeah I'm just making sure so
anyway she just I mean she's I mean just
screaming me like they didn't take this
flag down I cannot believe this is up I
mean she had lost her [ __ ] man and I'm
like yeah oh triggered to the extreme
and I'm like will you [ __ ] leave gay
people alone you know I mean and that's
where it started she has had a hard on
for me ever since because everybody drug
her so hard about her stupid little
temper tantrum so now every time my face
comes up she's like and she and she
loves to call me Paulie because in one
of my videos I said look my sister calls
me Paulie and nobody the [ __ ] else keep
that [ __ ] name out of your mouth okay
so now now she just loves to call me
Paulie but anyway she goes off on this
thing because she found out I went to
the White House and I was invited to the
White House and and that just oh my God
you can just see it just underneath her
skin man it's like
I loved it dude I love it but anyways
you'll see in the video well yeah so
let's let's let's listen to um
Allison here and before we start this I
want to say that she just came from
somewhere she came from somewhere she
didn't come from nowhere she came from
somewhere you'll you'll know what I mean
when I start playing it I just want to
point that out that Allison here
definitely came from somewhere not
nowhere because she's white I think
that's what she's saying but let's
listen this blue check mark named
Brooklyn dad underscore defiant is a
literal nobody who came out of nowhere
oh but he's got a blue check mark so he
must be important right
you can see here he tweeted at the White
House with these awesome resistors zoom
in to spot your faves
resistors what exactly are you
pro-government establishment shills
resisting such a joke anyway this
happened close to the same I want to
stop there because I I don't know if
she's watched my show I mean you are on
here every once in a while Texas Paul so
maybe she will come watch this but what
we are existing you dumbass is fascism
that's what we're resisting you you
fascist that's what we're resisting okay
I'll continue same time Dylan and
Company took their little field trip to
the White House and are clearly inviting
groups of paid influencers to spread
their garbage propaganda can you pause
it for a second when she like does that
head Bob what like okay my my wife had a
message for Allison
and it was do your [ __ ] Roots man
because you look like a reverse skunk
do your [ __ ] Roots okay
Jesus
ah okay let's let's continue and and
everyone pay attention to the roots
still for me it was this one
my number one fan text Holly in the same
photo as these Biden loving commies
the Biden loving commies she really
should have leaned in and gave the voice
what's wrong with her you know the
difference you know the difference
between Biden bringing people in like
Texas Paul and Trump accepting people to
come to the White House what's that
Trump was inviting people from the proud
boys like Enrique atario who actually
was part of you know the Insurrection on
January 6. so there's a big difference
uh but though she does have a theory of
your involvement so I'm yeah let's get
to why she thinks Texas Paul is part of
the deep State because I've never really
heard this one before to be quite honest
with you go ahead I would like to throw
a point out okay you see him either in
the middle Brooklyn dad defiant
a lot of his his
uh what he puts out on Twitter is him
and his son I mean it's really a cool
Twitter feed if you don't follow
Brooklyn dad to fight you should he's a
super nice guy he really is
but you notice she didn't pick out Grant
Stern
or no she didn't pick out Jeff teedrich
she didn't pick out any of the other
white dudes in that picture she went and
found because we all tweeted that
picture it didn't have to come from
Brooklyn Dad she picked a meat on
purpose but that's what I meant by
that's what I meant earlier by she came
from somewhere this is this white
supremacy because Brooklyn data Vine had
to come to nowhere because he's black I
came from somewhere because I'm white
that's that's the narrative she that's
the code talk I'm white I'm a white dude
I grew up in a racist white part of the
country that's what she's saying that's
what she's saying when she says he came
from nowhere meaning he's black and it's
because she who the [ __ ] is she who the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] I'm telling you she's
saying I came from somewhere only
because of my skin and he came from
nowhere because of his that's what the
[ __ ] she's saying let's let's keep
listen thing she's gonna tell you about
the Deep State she's got real good
information on Texas Paul here I'm not
sure where she dug this up but boy she's
got good info good Intel let's listen
for those of you that don't know Texas
poll is a contributor to far left Media
Group Midas Touch who somehow has 676
000 followers okay okay I want to stop
there I want to stop there because I
want I want to get full disclosure here
I want to get full disclosure for anyone
who doesn't know and we've been trying
to hide it Gabe for a long time we are
associated with minus touch in that
we've done a lot of production for them
on their live on their Channel we
actually bone end of the week for folks
that don't know it goes over on their
channel uh that has 670 some thousand I
don't know what she's saying here
um followers somehow somehow someway and
the other thing too I want to mention
that we are also on their Facebook page
so just want to give full clarity here
uh that that me and Gabe are now I guess
we're CI agents too because
you're gonna find it out here you're
gonna find out here soon because those
are my missions to those bunkers I've
been going to right well that that could
be the Deep State Texas ball
she's about to accuse you of being part
of the CIA is what she's going to do
here
well you know
that's out of the bag now oh uh oh let's
let's listen let's listen to you that
was such a sweet gig man that was such a
sweet gig well let's listen to how she
how she uh presents it to the public I
suppose that's the beauty of not having
to deal with censorship and getting your
post boosted in a completely rigged
algorithm again it all makes sense when
you realize these losers are all sell
out puppets to The Establishment we all
know the CIA is all over social media
why wouldn't they boost liberals and
radicals to further push their agenda to
manipulate the system
did she I I you know I keep listening to
this I listen to it four or five times
last night and I was like and and of
course Gabe's what was that comes to
mind like what was what was that and I
rewind it and I re-watch it rewind it
re-watch it I'm like I can't figure out
exactly what she's saying is she saying
that the CIA is the cabal or the cabal
is controlling the cim I'm not really
sure exactly you know the cart or the
horse Chicken and the Egg type thing I'm
not sure I mean we work for him and I
don't even know I mean I I just look
I'll just I get a direct deposit from a
guy that I call Uncle George now I don't
know where that money comes from now if
that's like a 50 50 split giving it all
away Gabe I'm sorry I just figured if
she she made you're telling Texas false
Secrets right now if she made this big
reveal I feel like we might as well just
come out in the open and own it you know
yeah that that's that's uh that clip
that's going around is is not the first
the first one she just flat out says
we're CIA but the funny part is Jeff
teedrich came back I don't know if y'all
follow him on he he's another great one
he uh he's like damn it between cash and
the CIA checks and cash in the George
Soros checks all I can do is run back
and forth between the bank I can't get
any work done anymore
these checks these these deep State
checks are just uh clogging up clogging
up everything clogging up everything of
course we know this can I clarify
something though yeah go ahead can I
clarify something okay this cost the
American people nothing it cost you
nothing I paid my own flight okay
everybody there paid their own flight
and we got last minute notification that
this was actually going to happen
because we didn't know I mean the White
House is actually doing work people I
mean these are some sharp sons of
[ __ ] and I'm very glad I got to go
there and meet we got to meet some very
very very very very intelligent
individuals we did and I'm very glad
they're doing their job and letting me
do mine where because we do very
different jobs these people are are are
you know keeping your interest rates
down these people are are working their
ass off doing a lot of really good work
for you part of what she says there is
that we're pro-government
you [ __ ] right I am
you [ __ ] ride on pro-government the
government does very important things
for you people and the fact that we want
people in government that are competent
and intelligent and do things like you
know let me let me take you back to the
Reagan days
when this exact scenario happened under
Reagan when we came out of uh I don't
know if everybody remembers the Embargo
and all the [ __ ] with Jimmy Carter where
the you know all that we were in a
financial disaster Reagan gets into
office the Embargo ends because he made
a deal with the [ __ ] Saudis to end
the Embargo and it anyways long story
short we had an economic explosion well
Republicans don't do their [ __ ] job
they don't do their [ __ ] job so we
had 16 19
[ __ ] interest rates just blowing up
all over the place because they were
spending like drunk [ __ ] sailors
and it's just idiots they're just
[ __ ] idiots and now we've got the
Biden Administration same situation
coming out of covet the economy is
blowing up so we're having inflation
because of demand and they're slowly
creaking those interest rates up just
ever so slowly to just put a slight
break on the economy a little drag a
little parachute on the back to slow it
down so we've got three and a half
percent interest rates
so yeah I'm [ __ ] pro-government
because that's their [ __ ] job and
they're [ __ ] good at it
oh it's funny when you when you live in
democracy and you're actually the
government and they're she's like ah
your pro government like yeah I'm Pro
the people yeah that's kind of I'm proud
actual democracy not trying to overthrow
the government one other thing I want to
mention about this clip one other thing
I want to mention is um she's claiming
she claims in there that somehow the CIA
and the algorithms are in some favor
favorable thing for a leftist or
something I'm not sure exactly how the
the the algorithm identifies
um no Allison people just don't like
your sorry sure last that's it that's
that's the algorithm do people like you
oh let's show that do people not like
you that's not really good for business
let's not show that you know I mean it's
a [ __ ] bit of AI right there man you
know [ __ ] people like let's let's put
that in the window [ __ ] people don't
like let's put that in the [ __ ] trash
can with Allison [ __ ] [ __ ] Barbie
Steinberg
that's the whole [ __ ] algorithm okay
well um speaking of trash
um there's some breaking news Robbins
pointing it out and I I it happened
right before on air but
um the AP has the story here we've got
um uh breaking uh this is about an hour
ago uh former white house chief of staff
Mark Meadows was ordered by a judge to
testify before the special grand jury
that's investigating rather than
president Donald Trump and his allies
illegally tried to influence George's
2020 election now this is the same
special grand jury that Lindsey Graham
has got a stay on um testifying from
Clarence Thomas while the Supreme Court
is going to draw that to a decision now
again I believe that it's just a delay
tactic for the election that's all
Clarence Thomas is doing he's running
he's running game for republicans and
fascists uh by not by by punting this
decision and kicking this can past the
election so that that people can't make
decisions based on what the Supreme
Court's going to do I believe that's uh
there so I don't know if Mark Meadows is
going to try the same tactic
um here
um but it does appear the AP is
reporting that a a judge has ordered
um Mark Meadows to testify listen
normally and and again from my
experience normally a grand jury when
they're questioning like Lindsey Graham
or Mark Meadows
um they're not the Target right they're
trying to find out information about the
Target and in this case the target seems
to be the guy who was trying to steal an
election in the state of Georgia and
particularly this County
um and that is why this prosecutor is
having such a Heyday here in getting
these people to testify because there's
evidence see that is why the judge is
actually forcing these [ __ ] to
testify is because the prosecutor in
this case with the special Grand Jury
convened has evidence that these people
know this stuff and need to testify to
these facts and the judge agrees because
there is a Target in this investigation
and that Target is your orange Mussolini
Jesus and that is not going to be good
for him now I actually believe Texas
Paul
um because I want your comments on this
case in particular but I actually think
the documents case is a much faster case
that they're making the feds are are
probably
light years ahead of where everyone
believes they are because the feds have
been on the documents case for months
now we're just now seeing part of their
investigation that's the other thing
about an investigation that a lot of
folks don't understand is uh the the
search warrant that was served at
Mar-A-Lago that wasn't the first step
that was not the first step in their
investigation that was many steps into
the criminal investigation into Donald
Trump and they're moving forward fast
now he's trying to stall with the
Supreme Court we know that didn't work
he's trying to stall with the special
Master that's not going to work because
that's not what a special Master is but
in this case in Florida in particular
um what what do you see at me because I
actually see Mark Meadows and Lindsey
Graham happening to testify here I see
that Rudy Giuliani and all the likes
them are going to testify Donald Trump
is definitely in the Target here and I
believe there's going to be State
charges in Georgia brought against
Donald Trump
I agree 100 with everything you just
said the only thing that I would call to
a people's attention is um pay attention
to what mango Mussolini is crying about
he knows he knows where his he's going
to get rocked he knows where he's going
to spend his time in jail over and it is
the documents case because that is the
most cut and dried easy here's the
[ __ ] documents here's where they
[ __ ] were this [ __ ] took him
there's the communications where we told
them to give them the [ __ ] back and
here's where he told us he wants a deal
before he gets him back and nobody
anywhere has any confusion about that
case at all and it carries a good amount
of jail time that's why he is always
squawking about that yeah isn't evidence
a [ __ ] especially when you're
incompetent and you just leave [ __ ]
lying around I don't know your office
right it's one of those things here's
the thing I mean even Trump this past
weekend he was in Robstown Texas and he
you know of course blabbed on and said a
bunch of [ __ ] and lies about stuff
and he was like they subpoated me they
subpoenaed me they sent me a subpoena
and it's like yeah because they want you
to testify so he's over here complaining
that he has to testify uh to his
involvement in January 6th and this
attempt to overthrow the government and
uh you know keep himself in power by
rigging the election
and then you've got uh Alina Haba on um
what was it she was on
where wasn't she on she's right right
she's been running around with him a lot
lately she was out front in this
documents thing and then she went into
hiding for a while now she's back out
when she showed up she was on you know
uh Trump farts one when they went to
Robstown uh Texas and then she was just
on Eric bowling show on Newsmax uh last
night and she was talking about how
Trump has no problem being deposed and
giving testimony and talking to the
January 6th committee and then and the
first thing that comes to mind here is
there were two outcomes one which he has
never agreed even though he put that
14-page rambling on about [ __ ] hoax
this and election this [ __ ] whatever
was 14 pages never actually said yeah I
will come and I will testify in response
to their subpoena never did that
and also right and we have to remember
that Trump is notorious for pleading the
fifth even though he said on multiple
occasions only guilty people plead the
fifth the mob pleads of fifth why would
you take the fifth if you're innocent
all these things if you've got nothing
to hide and there really is no crime
then you should have no problem coming
forward and giving your testimony but he
won't and he can't because he is guilty
he's hiding he is afraid he is going to
project onto his cult oh they subpoenaed
me ah can you believe it it's I have one
I have one question for you I have one
question for he gave Texas Paul you've
stuck around for the whole show I don't
know if you have to go or not um but I
do have one okay okay okay
um Gabe I got one for a question for you
yeah did you call it air fart one
Trump farts one not farce farts no farts
because this is an an evolution here
because everyone's been going air farce
one I like air far
oh yeah yeah just like just all the way
because here's the thing we have to
remember that after Trump lost the
election
there was and this is what this is what
the reports came out there was so much
flatulence and for people who don't know
what that is that's [ __ ] farts there
were so many farts that were happening
in the Oval Office that aids were having
to essentially detox they were [ __ ]
Seance and they had their [ __ ] sage
and their Yankee Candles and all that
[ __ ] trying to clear the smell of
the fast food smarts that Trump was just
[ __ ] gorging himself with so he was
he was mad and he was upset he was down
in [ __ ] doc uh Diet Coke and upset
that he lost a Biden which we know he
was acknowledging in private and he was
[ __ ] gorging he was [ __ ] oh I saw
this video he was [ __ ] gorging this
food as a as kind of like I'm sad and I
want to eat my my feelings kind of
moment but he just [ __ ] farted
everywhere in the Oval Office and
everyone was like we can't even meet in
here and we've got to [ __ ] clean this
place out does anyone have Febreze in
Texas fall you got to take on the farts
and just dude leave my McRibs alone dude
well I have very few [ __ ] addictions
very few [ __ ] addictions I'm not a
drinker I don't do drugs but when the
[ __ ] McRib comes out
I'm all over that [ __ ] like white on
rice okay I don't know what it is about
him make her head but leave my [ __ ]
memories alone okay I want to tell you
something I want to tell you something
because
um everyone's saying this is the
farewell to her which I think is all a
bunch of [ __ ] they're trying to get
you to go buy as many maker ribs as you
possibly can
um but but here's what I want to say
there is a video
that came out to show how they're made
or whatever and I watched a bit of it
and I actually it did not it did not
discourage me from eating a McRib at all
um not in the in the slightest um um I
am from the Midwest and everyone knows
that I absolutely love McDonald's and
McRib is a favorite of mine too Texas
fall so
um if you [ __ ] think you're
gonna take our government away from us
just try and take our [ __ ] McRibs
away from us try that try that
[ __ ]
um so so I but I but I I think it's
funny that all this stuff collides right
because here we are talking about Trump
and and the Trump plane Trump farts one
and the um the actual that McRib as
delicious as it is it probably isn't
actually qualified as food but it is
delicious nonetheless
um and how it's made but all these
things Collide in our world right they
all Collide in one moment and that is
what is about to happen with Donald
Trump and Maga Republicans this is all
going to collide in one moment one big
Crescendo because listen folks
stories are great stories and they
happen because of Human Condition okay
now The Human Condition here is that
this is going to catch Donald Trump
his entire life he is skated he escated
the scrutiny just the same way that
McRib has skated the scrutiny up until
now that it is food or it is whether
it's food or not food
and I'm telling you in history this is
going to be a moment that history will
remember as the entirety of all their
transgressions all their [ __ ] all
their corruption and all their crime is
going to collide with them just the same
way that the McRib collided with this
video of an employee showing you how
McRibs really aren't that much of food
but they still are delicious just like
Donald Trump is not as smart as he
thinks he is he's not as smart as he
thinks it is the trumpladites the
mongolites are not as smart as they
think they are but but they are still
criminals and they will pay the price
that is how it's going to go here that's
just how it's going to go and I hate to
you know bring the McRib into this but
you know how could you not
and you know I want just one thing I
want to throw out for people that may
not know this but the uh the documents
case is going to be the easiest case but
it may not be the be the one that you're
really really hoping for
because I mean pardon me I'm saying it
backwards the documents case is easy and
it's probably the one you're going to
want to hope for because
everybody would like to think that
treason carries a lot of jail time and
you know folks
the conviction down in Georgia
if he gets nailed to the [ __ ] wall
down in Georgia for doing this
man it's months that he's going to spend
in jail a few months the minimums on
that document case he will spend years
in jail
are some of the most severe obstruction
is way obstruction is going to is going
to bury him Way Beyond any conspiracy
that he stole these documents or sold
them or gave them away whatever the hell
he did with them whatever the [ __ ] he
was actually doing with these documents
because that's the thing I think we
don't know yet
um that that that that the charges and
the indictments and the prosecutors are
going to sniff out here but the
obstruction we know what he was doing we
know he was obstructing and that's what
you think about these big cases are big
big convictions I want you to think back
to reality winner
yeah okay
she released
one classified document
one and spent six years in jail right
yeah Trump isn't worried about what's
going down down in Georgia he's not he's
not because as old as he is that judge
is gonna if he's completely convicted he
may get like a Steve Bannon sentence six
months something like that you know and
he doesn't want to do six months don't
get me wrong he doesn't want to do six
months but this documents case
he'll die in prison he will [ __ ] die
in prison well it's it he'll he'll get
with the obstruction charges alone if he
goes all the way and what I mean by go
all the way is to a jury trial and if
he's given the toughest sentence that he
possibly can just for the obstruction
charge alone not the documents itself
but the obstruction charge alone he will
get a dirty 30. it is 20 years and 10
years probation and and he will serve
almost every single day of that the same
way that Steve Bannon is going to serve
every single [ __ ] day of his four
months Stephen is not getting out of the
four months folks everyone keeps saying
oh he's skated no he is not he is going
to serve every mother [ __ ] day of
that four months yeah for people that
don't know a a state charges one in nine
for good behavior uh a federal charge is
nine and ten right you will serve nine
out of every ten days that you're
sentenced to if you engage in perfect
prisoner Behavior
[ __ ] up when he went Federal he [ __ ]
up when he was Federal let me let me
give you another fact on federal
sentences
um anything it's nine and ten anything
over a year anything under a year is
every single [ __ ] day it's 10 and 10
under a year if you were if you are a
year and under on your sentence it is 10
and 10. now he'll get he'll get the
credit for the one day that he was perp
walked because they have to consider
that um detention so he will get a
credit for that one day but he will
serve every let's see band if you're
listening you're going to serve every
[ __ ] day of that four months every
day now the the likelihood that Steve
Bannon gets other charges depending on
what his involvement was in the state
elector scheme we'll we'll have to see
we'll have to see about that but um I
just want to show you well I'm gonna
keep the volume off
um because it's egregious with they're
doing to our democracy but what this
person is doing to the McRib Texas ball
is absolutely egregious by showing us
the truth by showing us the truth of the
McRib look at this thing I think it
looks delicious already
um you know they look like like they
look like rafts that would go on a like
[ __ ] Huckleberry Finn right down the
river what's wrong with that okay I'm
gonna lose half my [ __ ] audience here
when I say you
I eat Spam people yes I love spam spam
is actually made out of some pretty
Choice Cuts cook it yeah are you crazy
you open the can you lick the jelly and
you take a cracker and you slice it
that's that's the that's the line all
right all right all right everyone we
love having Texas ball on here on
Tuesdays but uh now the facts of bear
Delight we know who Texas ball truly is
now and he is a spam jelly liquor
um this is uh news to us
um no I'm just I'm just kidding Texas
Paul I hope you don't actually eat Spam
uncooked but I'll tell you I'll tell you
how I like it I'll tell you how I like
it I like to cut it up really thin and
just fry it like bacon that's that's how
I like them that's what that's my
favorite fam spam rice and eggs
eggs okay and let me ask you something
okay to be honest with you here just
we're
spam is made out of actually made out of
choice cuts of meat people don't know
that people know that's why it's like
350 a freaking can and my wife won't let
me buy it but you know I mean it's a
little can like this big and it's 350.
GoFundMe for spam project
man she never lets me have it but anyway
you're in the kitchen licking the jelly
off the son of a [ __ ] I wonder why she
doesn't let you have it Jesus Christ oh
my God you go ahead sorry I smear it on
a cracker damn it I don't lick it off
the spam other people might want a piece
you know but anyways
God Jesus Christ oh [ __ ] licking spam
oh God I can see I can I can see I can
see Texas ball on his front porch in his
rocking chairs opening up a can of spam
with his cup of coffee having his
breakfast there with some saltine
crackers in the canis man do you put it
on Saltines are Ritz which which is it
nah spam's got to go on a Saltine man I
mean rich is two two two delicate for
spam two buttery too delicate it's got
to be a Saltine or one hold together you
know but you guys ever have a Spam
musubi do what spam musubi I don't know
tell them it's uh it's it's spam rice
and uh seaweed and it's uh you know it
cooked it's got a good way is this it's
like spam Sushi is that what this is oh
yeah oh yeah essentially yeah I uh easy
Texas ball we don't need to have a uh we
don't need oh my God we got you
basically you basically you have a you
have a piece that's maybe like what a
quarter inch a kind of thick cut right
of spam oh sure you do it thicker yeah
you do a little thicker okay you have it
then you you know it's usually done like
an oval shape and then underneath there
you've got sticky rice with it and then
you wrap it in seaweed it is so good
it is it is Allison's talking about it
in in Hawaii I I I think it is a big
thing in Hawaii right yeah like I've got
I've got a buddy from Guam you know
that's where I first got it from my
buddy from Guam that I went to college
with he's the one who introduced me to
spam he was like oh yeah I got spam rice
and eggs I got my soup I got this I was
like oh my God I'm not I'm never leaving
this place I'm gonna have this all the
time well Texas Paul can tell you if
you're a white person and ever been in a
trailer park in America that's where you
found spam I that's where I am man
that's where I found spam I was like
hell yeah let's do this you mean it's
meat in a can Hills to the yeah poor
folk love them to this man now of course
now if there's ever yeah because if
there's ever a nuclear war it's going to
be me and a cockroach eating a can of
spam that's what it's going to be
because that's all that'll be left man
because
while the CIA will see to that
bunker tons of spam Gabe you know I had
it I I had it one time they took a
pineapple apple and they sliced a little
oh yeah a little thin slice of pineapple
in there and you put a little Wasabi on
there to make it spicy oh my god dude
I might have to go out and find that
today in my neighborhood yes you guys
are fancy with your spam I literally we
just we sliced her up then cooked or
like bacon threw it on a piece of bread
and ate to some [ __ ] like that was I
mean that's the way to do it but if
you're looking to kind of open up your
your food palette and your taste buds to
a world that you've never experienced
every Tuesday I eat tacos in Texas fall
I'll take a picture because Gabe's like
what you're eating is not Tacos yeah
like last night we made tacos you know
yeah tortillas skirt steak we had can
you make can you make wait wait can you
make Spam tacos is that a thing I mean
you could make anything tacos if you
want it's long actually a guy was just
talking about using chicharrones instead
of uh Saltines and I'm telling you I've
never done it I've never done it but
that sounds freaking good man a little
hot sauce yeah
I'm telling you for people that don't
know what chicharrones are chicharon is
a fried pork skin yeah they're pork skin
wow well I mean pork on pork why not
right I mean you throw that on with a
little bit of lime and some chili
holy you know I think we're just gonna
abandon politics and turn this into a
full exclusive Food Channel uh the Tony
Michaels podcast is now a food podcast
um everyone out there listening tune in
every single Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central we will be talking
about food
um at some point in the show Texas Paul
it's been great having you I'm glad you
stick you stuck around for for the
entirety of the show every time you're
here it's longer and longer and longer
we didn't get to the shitlist Roundup
today but I'm glad to have you uh the
audience missed you yesterday I know
they missed you um they were in this
always a pleasure to be here
I mean he was on the road but if he was
on the show yesterday you know and not
today we wouldn't have had this whole
Allison that is true conspiracy expose
when did she do this video when did she
do it right was it last night that she
that she yesterday she busted it out
yesterday morning
oh okay so is this on your show on oan
or is this just uh her uh yeah oh okay
are you are you gonna do a response to
her video we want to know already done
oh already done is it scheduled on the
uh on the CIA network over there I don't
know yet I don't know when I get off of
here I'll check with him to find out but
I'm sure it is CIA is going to post it
on their Network and make sure that the
rigged algorithms push it out to all the
masses to brainwash them and uh I feel
like once once I see your response I
feel like I have to do uh what was that
because this is so [ __ ] stupid Tony I
I do want to I don't mean to like slam
the brakes on this but I want to say
thank you man uh I you're
you're part of your rant you were
talking about fetterman and a lot of
people a lot of people don't know this
but I'm deaf as a rock band I am I'm I'm
almost completely deaf I can hear very
low tones I can hear you walking up
behind me but I can't hear a damn word
you say I actually am almost completely
deaf
all right
from shooting I've been competitive
shooting my whole life same thing that's
going on with a lot of people that
served in the military they they were
told that the little spongy [ __ ] that
you put in your ear would protect your
hearing and it and it didn't it doesn't
don't ever do that if you shoot with
your kids make sure that they wear over
the hair protection okay I'm deaf
because of that and I watched the
fetterman debate and I have to tell you
I gradually lost my hearing so I didn't
have the confusion but I have talked to
people and helped people that have lost
their hearing due to Industrial accident
to explosions to things like that and
you do not understand
John fetterman has not lost his brains
in his smarts
but you don't understand what it's like
to not hear your own voice
I mean it's very confusing it's very
very difficult very confusing the guy is
all there
and I'm telling you he can serve as your
senator because he's not going to be up
in front of a camera with Dr [ __ ]
smug face prick dick [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] sorry Turkish [ __ ]
Oz
smug ass [ __ ] I wanted to [ __ ]
slap him off that [ __ ] stage last
night every time fetterman responded Oz
was like see see he can't talk he can't
that [ __ ] can talk just fine
that was the worst setup in the world
for him I understand because of the
hearing loss and I'm telling you
fetterman is all there he is all there
he's 100 can serve as your Senator I'm
giving you my word the man can serve as
your Senator he absolutely when he gets
Beyond
just it's it's a bit of confusion
when you can't hear I mean you don't
understand what losing a sense is like
I mean people that you know you know try
going around your day closing your eyes
for the day and how confused and
difficult it would be for you to just
communicate I mean
because
I don't know I just want to thank you
Tony I really do appreciate your opening
it was spot on 100 percent and uh
somebody with profound hearing loss
um I I
I was enraged by Oz's smugness
I mean if you just saw his face if you
ever got to get a chance to go back and
watch that debate every time fetterman
answered and he would trip over a word
or whatever I thought Oz was going to
whip his dick out and start jerking off
I mean he was so
[ __ ] smug last night I wanted to just
punch him right in his [ __ ] throat he
is just a piece of [ __ ]
prick well also you know he's a I mean
he's a quack doctor but also he's a
doctor so you would you would hope that
a doctor would have empathy towards
someone's situation instead of try to
capitalize and make fun of it right why
would you shame someone for something
that you clearly know what's going on
and that really does show you I mean
outside of the fact that he said that in
abortion or the the health of you and
your child is between you your doctor
and your local politician because your
mayor [ __ ] up but when they said that
clearly folks when they show you who
they are you better [ __ ] believe him
well I believe that Pennsylvania said
saw someone yesterday
um who was fighting for them who wasn't
going to give up who has that
Pennsylvania Rust Belt Spirit who is who
is going to get knocked down but going
to come up and start swinging at you
sons of [ __ ] and he's going to do
everything he can to swing for the
people of Pennsylvania I think that's
going to ring true and I think Dr Oz
everyone knows he's a carpetbagger and
the line where fetterman tells him maybe
next time you should pretend that you're
from Vermont and go run against Bernie
Sanders since you want to put Bernie
Sanders in your mouth so much I thought
it was beautiful I thought it was well
delivered and I think I think fetterman
even though he dripped over a few words
last night did a beautiful job
um and I think he made he made Dr Oz
look like the like the piece of [ __ ]
that he truly really is and that he's a
fake of phony and a fraud and it's not
surprising that Donald Trump would
endures a fraud
what I saw was that fetterman has balls
like [ __ ] coconuts that's what I saw
because let me tell you that guy knew he
was going to have to read every word you
just try to keep up with that man I mean
I'm I I've got a stack of books here you
can't see it I mean I'll turn my camera
I got a stack of books here this [ __ ]
tall I read all the time I'm a pretty
fast damn reader but you try to keep up
with a debate and what your opponent's
saying that dude knew he was going to
have to do that and he knew that he was
going to have to assemble his thoughts
and and do it as quickly as possible and
you could see it on his face he was
trying to man just as fast as he could
so he didn't have those long delays he
was trying really [ __ ] hard to make
it quick for you and me
and I'm telling you that dude's got
balls like [ __ ] coconuts because he
knew he was going to be doing it against
a guy that spent his life on television
his life in front of a camera just
running his mouth man and and I'm
telling you well I I think I think it
was a great thing and everyone in
Pennsylvania everyone around the country
if you can vote now go vote now go vote
now and encourage three people to in to
vote and them to find three people to
encourage to vote Texas Paul thanks for
joining us I just want to add one thing
yeah go ahead I know I know that uh
Olivia and others were reporting this
down in in Texas they uh when you do
vote at least I've only seen it in Texas
I forget the county but if you do vote
make sure that when you are voting that
your actual vote is counted the way that
you want I know last night yes yesterday
there were some votes in Texas that were
reporting the opposite for people who
were voting one way or the other like if
they were voting for that literally
happened to me the last time Ted Cruz
and and better work faced off I I better
bet better won that race I guarantee you
because when it got to the the final as
I was tallying everything it was correct
when they kicked you that last page and
says confirm
mine had Ted [ __ ] cruise on the top
and you think I voted for Ted Cruz
you're out of your [ __ ] mind I
literally I called the lady over I said
whoa hey you know and she was like
jumped out of her skin I said you need
to get over here and she backed it up
fixed it sent it through and said well
we're gonna have to shut this machine
down I'm like well we're gonna have to
[ __ ] take this machine to [ __ ]
Washington is what we're gonna have to
do because this [ __ ] just voted
for Ted Cruz on its own right and I'm
telling you people when you get to the
last page always whether you're in Texas
or [ __ ] Vermont look at the sum the
summation and make sure that what you
voted for is there right well here in
Missouri we still in most most cases we
still vote on paper ballots and you feed
the ballot into the machine
um and that's how it's counted so but it
regardless go get your vote counted make
sure you're careful make sure you're
paying attention whether it's your
mail-in ballot on how you're mailing it
in because every State's different these
Republicans are [ __ ] with you that
you have to be absolutely perfect so
make sure make sure you do your due
diligence so your vote is counted
because we have to count every single
one of these votes it is super important
that you do this for your democracy
because it is your way of life that is
at State Texas Paul
um tell us about your YouTube channel
real quick I've got some announcements I
got to make and then we're gonna we
gotta run tell us about you yeah Special
show tonight should you catch me do a
search for Texas Paul on channels on
YouTube there will be an announcement
that's going to come out from the live
tonight me and Tennessee Brando are
doing a very special show tonight we're
inviting women on to take our place and
talk about Roe v Wade we're we're we're
inviting people in and we're going to
have listen to what women have to say
about row tonight so please if you get a
chance join us tonight for TNT I I think
it's going to be a fantastic show so
everyone go follow Texas Paul's YouTube
channel just just go type it into
YouTube right now uh we'll uh we'll
we'll put it in the uh the chat here if
you need it um it's for you to go follow
Texas Pawn YouTube and watch that
conversation night Texas apologize
always thanks for joining us I
appreciate the extended conversation
um I know it's Wednesday but Texas Paul
we appreciate you every single time
thank you my friend
foreign
guys love you too man so Gabe um wow
what a great conversation with Texas
Paul we really smoked out a lot of
things there um you know he is
definitely confirmed um he's been
exposed been revealed as a CIA deep
State operative apparently
um for the Twitter algorithms that are
rigged or some [ __ ] I don't know exactly
what the hell did the cat is out of the
bag whoosh meow
um speaking of um cat out of the bag I
guess the can is out of the bag that
everyone loves
this zip up hoodie from the
store.donymichaels.com it's the freedom
to oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty you [ __ ] anymore on it is
the hoodie at stored that the Johnny
michaels.com you can get a pullover
hoodie you can also get a sweater I also
get the T-shirt but you know what Gabe
everyone needs to stay warm while
they're voting and I got one of these
the other day and again I forgot to
bring it on today but it is super warm I
put it on yesterday I had to take it off
I was sweating it's so warm so go to
store.thedonymichaels.com grab your
hoodie today stay warm while you're out
there standing in line boating and let
them know that they will not take away
your rights it is your right to your
freedom and your Liberty it is a thing
that we do here on the pro-democracy
side Gabe Sanchez noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific every single weekday
Monday through Friday on YouTube Twitter
and twitch follow us here on YouTube go
over to Twitch Twitter Facebook we're on
the Midas touch Facebook page if you're
on the minus touch page Facebook page
right now go follow us at the Tony
Michaels we will post some memes with
some curse words in there they're always
great everyone same time same place
tomorrow maybe we'll have more reveals I
don't know maybe there's all kinds of
stuff to reveal who knows who could
possibly know Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon